hello I'm vigorously andrew heaton and
you're watching mostly weekly I'm sure
you had the same thoughts I did watching
the Comey testimony this is like the
BDSM stuff from Fifty Shades of Grey and
I think the parallels are pretty
self-evident I understood that I served
at the pleasure of the president the
pleasure of the President of closure of
the brosman he couldn't possibly be
having dinner with me alone in his the
president United States he told me
repeatedly with me alone the pleasure of
the program saying I hope this I took it
as this is what he wants me to do this
is what he wants me to do
I took it repeatedly this is what he
wanted me to do before you reproach me
god that's hot you see the stenographers
this is a good as time as any to tell
you that I am a Bureau sexual I am
aroused by procedural things in
government
[Music]
so this was a great week for me not so
much for James Comey whose testimony
about Trump's behavior had some strong
parallels with sexual harassment let's
go through the facts Comey is stunned
when President elect Trump invites him
to a private dinner where he asks him
for something inappropriate so much so
that Comey is stunned and unresponsive
and if there is an investigation
there'll be a independent prosecutor
congressional probe inquest of some sort
a lot of procedural stuff excuse me I
need to get something notarized the
clerk will report
HR 40 how you read that docket the
Donald is clearly a dominant like
Christian gray we went home with a
billionaire who spent a year negging
America and I know a lot of voters that
have low self-esteem would like to stay
with him but the issue here is abuse of
power and unlike Anastasia we never
signed a contract saying we wanted to
feel violated which is why I think the
world of politics could learn some
things from BDSM both of them involved
power structures consent and in some
cases bondage here are some proposals
government safer
I suggest that citizens can use a safe
word when the power abuse just isn't fun
anymore
pineapple ok haberdasher tippy-toe Hey
tippy-toe denial plan
legislators deny themselves the pleasure
of passing laws it's like political
edging I propose that just like Dom's
and subs sometimes switch places we get
to trade places with the government so
for a couple of days a year we get to
wield the sex baton and affirmative
consent let's talk about this from now
on no more 10 term senators no more
automatic spending increases and no more
creeping regulation anything the
government wants to do to us it has to
get affirmative proactive consent from
us now if you'll excuse me I've got some
jury duty to attend the stenographer
that I've been
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
you